all right today is Latin American
Mother's Day as Lauren has been telling
us right we've had the Mariachi we've
been talking about health and now we've
got to talk about a little bit of fun
joining us now in the kitchen Master
mixologist Jennifer McKenzie Jennifer
thank you again for coming back on the
show how's everyone doing add a little
spice to our Mother's Day flavor so
whether it's today or whether you decide
to wake up this weekend oh what you
making there so here we got the chop the
choco Vine okay Vine it's made with a
French Cabernet and Dutch chocolate with
a little hint of vodka and a little bit
of chili powder chili powder that spices
it up doesn't it or on the Rocks you
added the chili powder to this because
this itself if you buy the bottle it's
not it doesn't really spice okay how
much did you add I added two ounces of
the chocolate mine and then I added one
ounce of vodka and then just a teaspoon
of the Red Hot Chili Pepper okay can we
smell it can we smell it you can smell
the chili powder right I like get spicy
I know some people don't so maybe you'd
cut back a little if Mom's a little
sensitive but you know Latin American
Mothers they want that spice right they
want that heat and here we have this
strawberry mint Margarita okay this is
going to be made with the thess agave's
reposado you do about two ounces of that
I'm gonna go ahead and need that
Margarita she eyeballs it like you do
Heather oh yeah
I keep doing these cocktail segments
it's like somebody knows us right we're
getting good at it too we're gonna drink
enough I don't know that's really good
because you want to make sure you get
those strawberry flavors in here and
this is 100
of organic tequila
look at this only 68 calories per
serving what you feel good about is that
your poor or her poor
I got a heavy hand that's how I like to
drink them okay so there's your and what
was this called the strawberry mint
Margarita strawberry mint Margarita it's
also made with our organic strawberry or
organic margarita mix okay so you need
one two two ingredients two parts
strawberry mint lime Shake It Up over
ice with the Salted that looks really
refreshing and it's gonna be warm on
Mother's Day so this weekend so of
course today is Latin America wait so
this one has a spice so I I have to okay
are you gonna take a sip all right tell
us about the one with the jalapenos this
is the jalapeno this is going to be the
spicy Paloma oh yes oh I like Palomas
it's really refreshing so here we're
going to use the best Agaves organic
Blanco tequila now the Tres Agaves
actually has three types of tequila they
do the blanco Reposado and the Anejo
we're gonna do a little bit of lime
juice here with also the Tres Agaves
um agave nectar and that's going to be
going with a top off of grapefruit fresh
grapefruit juice
pop it off with a little jalapeno give
it a little spice not too spicy but yeah
refreshing but something great I mean
Sherry you're giving us hot temperatures
so these are great cocktails to enjoy
these will last all the way through the
weekend and Beyond especially during
your morning Jennifer you're normally a
Brooklyn Bowl yes right El Dorado
Cantina okay well thank you so much for
great ideas to entertain mom and keep
her refreshed while we're celebrating
her I love it okay choco Vine that's
that's where it's at Jennifer thank you
so much for coming back we love it
appreciate it